als ich vor drei jahren das ende des
fernsehens in fünf jahren vorausgesagt
habe
da habe ich mich einerseits aber
andererseits auch nicht tatsächlich
spielt online eine immer größere rolle
und wie beim telefon droht irgendwann
die abschaltung der alten technik die
verbreitung über internet bietet allen
sendern wie zu schauen so viele vorteile
dass es nur noch eine frage der zeit ist
wann satelliten terrestrisches tv und
kabel-tv abgeschaltet werden aber wo
habe ich mich dann gehört jetzt sind
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
anfang diesen jahres geschah etwas das
den fernsehfans die augen geöffnet hat
die handball weltmeisterschaft wurde
nämlich nicht im fernsehen übertragen
sondern im internet handball sponsor dkb
die deutsche kreditbank sprang ein und
übertrug die wm auf ihrer webseite
anders wäre eine übertragung nämlich
nicht möglich gewesen und jetzt kommt es
aus technischen und lizenzrechtlichen
gründen sprich eine übertragung im
fernsehen waren nicht möglich weil dort
die lizenzbedingungen nicht eingehalten
werden konnten
jedenfalls im free tv das ist nämlich
über die grenze hinweg nicht nur in
deutschland empfangbar und die lizenz
gab es aber nur für deutschland die ard
oder das zdf hätten dafür ihr programm
verschlüsseln müssen unmöglich nur im
internet konnte gewährleistet werden
dass die wm auch nur in deutschland
empfangen werden kann über ip adressen
ist ganz einfach zu ermitteln wo die
zuschauer jeweils die spiele sehen und
so kann der empfang exakt auf das
territorium begrenzt werden
tv kann das nicht eine veraltete
technologie und wer hätte gedacht dass
hier die alte technologie an ihre grenze
stößt im wahrsten sinne des wortes nur
ip technologie also die protokollierte
übertragung der daten ist dazu in der
lage das fernsehen wohlgemerkt als
technologie wird so schneller ausgedient
haben als wir bisher angenommen haben
denn durch die immer aggressiver
verteidigten lizenzen und erlösmodelle
werden solche gebietsschutz fragen immer
wichtiger und noch etwas wird fernsehen
das leben schwer machen
genau die programme die davon betroffen
sind live events und sportübertragung
profitieren von der ip-technologie nur
ihr können total flexibel ohne jede
einschränkung zusätzliche daten video
streams usw übertragen werden ein
fantastischer mehrwert den fernsehen
nicht bieten kann zudem sind im netz die
technischen entwicklungen viel schneller
hier gibt es bereits 4 k 360 grad und so
weiter ob es das noch über herkömmliche
tv technologie geben wird höchst
fraglich und inzwischen zeigte sich auch
in den daten der fernsehnutzung der
zenit ist überschritten bis 2010 gingen
die tägliche sehdauer im tv immer weiter
nach oben bis zu 223 minuten täglich
fast vier stunden im schnitt seitdem
passierte aber nichts mehr und es wächst
nur noch die internetnutzung im letzten
jahr so stark wie nie in der jungen
zielgruppe von 14 bis 29 jahren ist die
reichweite im internet inzwischen höher
als im fernsehen
es steht schon 51 zu 46 prozent dh mit
online-video werden 51 prozent der
jungen zuschauer täglich erreicht mit
dem fernsehen nur noch 46 prozent
letzte woche war ich auf dem panel des
web tv monitor der blm der bayerischen
landeszentrale für medien zu gast und
auch hier zeigte sich es kommt etwas in
bewegung immer professionellere angebote
erreichen netz immer mehr zuschauer
hinzu kommen die geänderten
werberichtlinien auf youtube träsch wird
immer öfter ausgeklammert und
hochwertige inhalte erzielen deutlich
höhere einnahmen schon 2010 hatte ich
das damals beim youtube video advisory
board gefordert erst jetzt 2017 wurde es
in die tat umgesetzt und das erst
nachdem sich die werbeindustrie
beschwert hatte zu erleiden jetzt hier
auch tolle und renommierte angebote und
youtube muss hier unbedingt noch
nachjustieren aber generell ist die
entwicklung in die richtung qualität
eine gute wenn sich nicht mehr rechnet
wird er verschwinden und qualitativ gute
programme haben bessere chancen es ist
eine vielversprechende entwicklung im
bereich online-video ach ja und wobei
ich mich geirrt habe auf der anderen
seite wird fernsehen noch lange leben
und die sehdauer wird nur langsam nach
unten gehen die generation fernsehen
wird nämlich immer älter und sieht immer
mehr fernsehen die 90 jährigen die zehn
stunden am tag fernsehen werden noch
lange für eine ordentliche
durchschnittliche sehdauer sorgen über
die neuen chancen von online-video
spreche ich übrigens morgen auf der b 3
biennale in frankfurt auf dem panel neue
plattformen neue formate neues geld für
weitere infos hier klicken um 11.15 geht
es los ich freue mich auf jeden der
kommt und hier geht es weiter mit dafür
drauf klicken die schule der zukunft
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt dran